I'm going to start with something a little
bit different today.
I think this is important.
I think this is a good way to get some insight
into some of the really like the worst talking
points and the worst propaganda right now
being spread by some on the right.
I think disappointment, something really disappointing
happened on Tuesday on the Joe Rogan podcast.
Dan Crenshaw took Joe Rogan for a ride.
I don't know how else to say it.
Dan Crenshaw is a Republican congressman and
he is increasingly in favor with Trump.
He came to prominence, sort of fell into favor
with Donald Trump when he defended Donald
Trump's handling of coronavirus, which is
I mean, I can't imagine a bigger failure for
Trump than coronavirus, a global embarrassment.
And Dan Cranshaw came to the forefront saying,
look at how great of a job actually Donald
Trump has done on this issue.
And sadly, Joe Rogan got taken for a ride
by Dan Crenshaw's slick but wrong claims about
all sorts of different things.
And the reason I'm saying that Crenshaw takes
Joe Rogan for a ride is that it seems pretty
clear that Dan Crenshaw knows that he's blessing.
Dan Crenshaw knows that when he tells these
lies, these are lies.
He's not ignorant.
He is smart enough to know that he's saying
untrue things.
And some of them he gets past Joe Rogan, some
of them is kind of B.S. Meter goes off and
he says, hold on a second.
Does that does that make sense or doesn't
it make sense?
But there's this sort of cult of personality
that's developed around Dan Crenshaw, as if
he's some epic truth teller of conservative
truths that are irrefutable.
But really, Dan Crenshaw, it's sort of Ben
Shapiro like with a lower pitched voice.
He says things that are wrong, lower pitched
voice and slower speaking cadence.
Dan Crenshaw, like Ben Shapiro, says things
that are wrong but says them confidently and
oftentimes people don't challenge him.
So let's jump in a thanks to Scott, one of
our viewers, for sending me some of the notable
moments from this interview.
Here is one moment on the topic of Medicaid.
To his credit, Joe Rogan's B.S. meter does
go off here, but Crenshaw's mildly prepared.
So let's take a look at it and then discuss.
Yeah.
So instead of spending all this money on on
Medicaid, for instance, OK, the people who
are eligible for Medicaid and even above that
rate and you can you could have a tiered program
instead of wasting all that money on a Medicaid
program that doesn't have improved outcomes.
By the way, every study shows this.
What do you mean by that?
It doesn't have improvement.
It means that when you compare people from
the same socioeconomic status and they're
in Medicaid or enrolled or they have no insurance
at all, their health outcomes are no different.
So, again, malarky, is that going around with
statistics?
A lot would a lot of studies have shown this,
but hold on.
You're talking about someone getting medical
care or not getting there?
No, because you always get medical care.
OK, so the claim is if you're going to do
this, you first have to be really clear as
to what the claim that's being made is.
The claim being made by Dan Crenshaw is that
people with Medicaid do no better in terms
of health outcomes than people with no insurance,
assuming they're of the same socioeconomic
status.
So two people who earn twenty two thousand
dollars a year, one has Medicaid, one has
no insurance.
Dan Cranshaw says they have the exact same
health outcomes because, as he says, people
with no insurance can still get care by going
to the emergency room and not paying their
bill or by going to a doctor and not paying
their bill or whatever.
So so Medicaid really does nothing, but it
costs money.
Medicaid is bad in that sense.
Dan Crenshaw cites that there's lots of studies
that say this, research this, and you will
very quickly figure out where this comes from.
This claim that people do no better on Medicaid
than without insurance, given the same socioeconomic
level.
All goes back to one study called the Oregon
Health Insurance Experiment.
This is from 2013.
This is like this is this is meat, right?
You need to understand this stuff to understand
these talking points they come up with.
This is a 2013 study.
And it looked in Oregon and said what happened
when Oregon did the Obamacare Medicaid expansion?
And a bunch of people who previously didn't
have health insurance got Medicaid.
And then we followed some of that people.
Now some of those people.
It's true.
The study claims that, quote, This randomized
controlled study showed Medicaid coverage
generated no significant improvements in physic.
Health outcomes in the first two years, but
it did increase use of health care services,
raised rates of detecting diabetes and managing
diabetes, lower rates of depression and reduced
financial strain.
So let's analyze each finding individually.
The main important one that is at issue with
Dan Cronshaw is the people who got the Medicaid
coverage generated no significant improvement
in measured health outcomes in the first two
years.
But when you look at the details, you very
quickly realize that this is an almost meaningless
claim.
How did they measure health outcomes?
They looked only at three factors and only
for two years.
The three factors that were used were blood
pressure, cholesterol and what's called Glik
hated hemoglobin level levels which measure
diabetic blood sugar.
And they tracked just those three indicators
for two years now.
I hope that it's becoming clear how slippery
that is.
Any other improvements?
Eliminating pain, treating infections sooner,
lowering BMI.
None of that is they're all they looked at
is blood pressure, cholesterol and glaciated
hemoglobin levels.
These aren't even close to the most common
reasons people go to doctors.
The most common reasons that people go to
doctors are skin issues of various kinds,
joint pain and arthritis, pain, back pain,
respiratory issues, including colds that start
to affect respiration, flu, bronchitis, pneumonia,
COPD, emphysema, anxiety and depression, neurological
issues, headaches and migraines.
And yes, you also have on that top 12 list,
but towards the bottom, cholesterol and blood
pressure.
So the study that Dan Crenshaw is talking
about, he may not even know what his talking
point that is talking point is actually based
on this study, it didn't measure anything
about changes or outcomes related to 10 of
the top 12 reasons people go to the doctor.
It's it's meaningless in this context, and
by the way, it only looked at two years, many
of these things unfortunately take longer
for people to successfully treat and improve
upon.
So when he says the people on Medicaid don't
do any better, measured only by looking at
cholesterol, blood pressure and diabetic blood
sugar doesn't make sense.
Very incomplete.
And by the way, the study also found that
when people got Medicaid after not having
it and you compare the two groups, they were
detecting that they were diabetic or prediabetic.
They were managing that at a higher rate.
Depression rates went down and financial strain
went down, which is a good thing.
So it's a complete and total gaslight.
Dan Crenshaw is spouting something that is
almost completely meaningless.
It's wrong.
It's the opposite of the truth.
And Crenshaw is really pernicious, specifically
because he sounds so normal and calm and confident
and knowledgeable when he says things that
are totally wrong compared to, for example,
like when you hear Madison Cawthorn speak,
he doesn't inspire confidence.
When you hear Madison, Marjorie Taylor Greene
or Lauren Bobert, not only are they saying
things that are wrong, they sound totally
not credible.
When Dan Crenshaw says things that are wrong,
he actually sounds credible.
Let's look at another example.
And this was something that came out like
whenever someone says, I want to make a list
of people like, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, look
like fascism.
Yeah.
This is you're getting dangerous here.
This is a weird thing you're doing because
the biggest lie of of this century is that
there's this like American right wing fascism
that the only fascism I see is, well, I mean,
those blatant example is the antifa crazies
who deliberately engage in fascist tactics
to to implement their little form of utopia,
but also like what we're talking about in
Georgia, all these corporations engaging what
they're engaging in.
This is fascism, this forced conformity.
Yes.
Like and fascism.
There's lots of kind of definitions.
Look at Dan Crenshaw.
Claim that everybody else is misstating what
fascism is, that some say fascism is only
Hitler, and he'll tell you what the real fascism
is.
And he says corporations expressing an opinion
about a law they don't like is fascism when
Coca-Cola criticizes the Georgia voting law.
Or says we're not going to do MLB says we're
not going to do business with Georgia, Dan
Crenshaw wants you to believe that that's
fascism and he liked this talking point so
much that he used it last night on Fox News
as well.
We won't we won't go to that.
Dan Crenshaw, much like Donald Trump used
to say, wants you to believe everybody else
is lying to you about what things are.
I will tell you the truth.
But then he lies to you.
He says all of these other people are saying
that this is fascism.
That's no, no, no.
The real fascism is antifa, which is an anti
fascist group and corporations criticizing
Georgia.
That's fascism.
Fascism is when a system of government or
a movement or a regime puts nation and sometimes
race above the individual and has centralized,
autocratic, authoritarian government, often
headed by a dictator with severe economic
and social regimentation and forcible suppression
of the opposition.
When a for profit corporation is free to say
we don't like this law, we might leave Georgia
and citizens are free to say, Oh, I like that
idea.
I'm going to support Coca-Cola, for example,
or I don't like what Coke is doing.
I'm not going to support them.
I'm going to boycott them.
That's not fascism.
That's free market economy.
That's it.
That's all it is.
But people fall for this stuff because he
sounds so confident when he says it.
Here's another whopper that we've dealt with
before on immigration.
So you think that most of the people that
are progressive that look at this immigration
issue and are more liberal and more they're
more open to this idea of open borders?
The reason why they're doing it is because
they're kind of compassionate, but they haven't
looked at the actual statistics of what this
means and what happens and why.
And what's the incentive is that would you
believe that would be a kind way, a kind way?
It depends on where they want more illegal
immigration because you want them to eventually
become citizens and vote for you.
Right.
So I think I think at the higher ends of the,
you know, the democratic patriarchy.
So Joe Rogan says right.
Like that makes obvious sense.
Democrats want more immigrants because the
immigrants will eventually become citizens,
vote for Democrats and so Democrats will win.
First of all, it's actually unclear whether
more immigrants becoming citizens really means
a substantively impactful majority of Democrats
over Republicans, certainly Latin American
immigrants other than Cubans and even some
Venezuelans who in sort of like an anti Maduro
anti Castro reaction, Cubans and some Venezuelans
tend to be sort of more to the right.
Other than that, Latin American immigrants
certainly lean left.
But the Cato think a Cato Institute, which
is a right wing think tank, researched this.
And they said the question of whether immigrants
are really more left or more right is a complicated
question with lots of moving parts.
The point is, even if immigrants skew left
55 to 45 or even 60 40, that margin this is
a really long play.
This is a stupid way to try to win elections,
because for every hundred thousand immigrants
who after five plus years remember, you come
to the US with a green card, takes a while
to get the green card.
You need to be in the country five years before
you can apply for citizenship.
Getting citizenship can take one to two more
years.
That's like seven to eight years for what,
a 60 40 margin after seven years for every
hundred thousand new citizens.
If it's 60 40, you're only netting 20000 voters.
Right.
This is a very stupid way to try to win elections.
And it's sort of like when the right says,
oh, Democrats are trying to win by having
people vote twice, like drive to one polling
place and vote and then drive to another polling
place and vote under a different name or whatever.
Do you understand how much work that is to
try to actually swing an election and much
the same way, you know, waiting around seven
years for like what's maybe a 55, 45 or 60,
40 margin on new citizens that are naturalized
voting for.
It's incredibly stupid.
So you really have to be political parties
are barely able to plan ahead two years.
And Dan Crenshaw wants you to believe that
Democrats on what is really a small margin
of Democrats over Republicans in terms of
naturalized citizens are planning seven to
eight years in advance as a strategy to win
elections.
It doesn't even pass the sniff test.
What do you think about it?
And again, unfortunately, because Dan Cranshaw
says it so confidently, people fall for it.
And if Joe Rogan is going for it, at least
partially, you know that many in his audience
are.
So I could go on and on a dozen such examples.
Dan Cronshaw totally taking Joe Rogan for
a ride with easily debunked nonsense and an.
Increasingly, Dan Crunchier is becoming a
hero of the right wing.
It's sad, but but it's also dangerous because
these bad ideas spread and they get repeated
with almost no critical thinking applied to
them whatsoever.
Let me know your thoughts.
In particular, if you saw this episode, you
can find me on Twitter at David Pakman.
The David Pakman Show is an audience supported
program, I would love it if you added your
name to the hat, sign up for a membership
at Join Pakman dot com.
You can use the coupon code better.
Twenty one
for
a beautiful discount.
You will get access to
the Daily Bonus Show in audio and video formats,
as well as a daily audio and video commercial
free stream of the daily episodes.
Sign up at Join Pakman Dotcom